my channel is sponsored by keeps which
means we will hear more from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
hello everyone i'm elaine welcome to my
channel where today we are doing another
q a this one is a gaming q a the next
one would be a personal q a where you
can ask me anything other than video
games movies tv whatever but you can
leave questions for either of them below
and i will just sort through both of
them i'm sorry that there's a weird
flickering
it's probably the camera auto adjusting
to the lighting i should turn the lights
on let me just i thought it would look
cooler but really it's just like my face
is blown out and it's flickering i'm
turning lights on okay problem solved
evil gaming zz said how do you feel
about take to acquiring zynga i know
you've had a lot to say about rockstar
in the past
huh yes timely look at us go um this
doesn't surprise me in the slightest i
think it was
12.8 4.7 billion um
that
take two interactive just bought zynga
for if you don't know zynga they are a
mobile gaming company primarily and
that's like double what microsoft paid
for bethesda um i am completely
unsurprised because it seems to be the
direction that take two has headed in
recently they had bragged about trying
to release hundreds upon hundreds of
games and the only way that you can do
that is with mobile gaming um i don't
think that you should be surprised if
absolutely every single game studio on
the planet starts coming out with mobile
games i think that that is the direction
in which we are headed it is an
inevitability because of the size of
that market when there are so many
people on iphones
or androids of course naturally you want
to get games in those people's hands so
that you can start making money off of
them too take two are they're publicly
traded which means that they run on
the stock market or rather make a lot of
decisions based on the stock market
means that they are a for-profit company
so is every other company in the games
industry of course they are for-profit
that is how they operate none of these
companies are actually doing anything
for the love of video games it is all
for profit that is what a business is
i'm not even saying that as a negative
that is just a fact the developers at
the studios are pretty often doing
things for the love of the craft i could
say that for myself and for everybody
that i work with but the companies
selling the products are just trying to
make money so yes this is wholly
unsurprising and was very clearly the
direction that take two was headed in
regardless now where it pertains to
rockstar i only have guesses and um you
know i worry that maybe my guesses are a
little bit too generous but i ultimately
don't know my guess with rockstar is
that they are one of the golden children
of take two's portfolio
because of grand theft auto online there
is also absolutely value when you go to
your shareholders and you talk into the
stock market you're saying look at the
studio that we have this is rockstar
games they made red dead redemption 2.
look at all these awards and the
metacritic score look this beautiful
studio we have i don't doubt that they
also have um a lot of love for what
rockstar makes
where that's concerned so what i suspect
is that take two will continue to
monetize everything that rockstar does
as much as they can um for example
making those recent gta ports they were
not made in-house at rockstar they were
made by another studio and they were not
very good unfortunately i was really
excited about those they will also
probably either make gta mobile games um
even though i think some of the older
games are available to play on mobile
but they will make you know new gta
mobile games and red dead games some way
to integrate shark cards onto every
platform ever being that they are so
monstrously profitable but i do not
actually think that this means
that we don't get gta 6 and we don't get
red dead redemption 3 which obviously is
like 20 years away gta 6 is currently in
development and
while i don't doubt that um take two is
going to be having a very strong hand
in how gta online functions and making
sure that they continue to make that as
profitable as possible and bring in new
players like does potentially gta online
just stay as a standalone that gets
updated that does not mean to me however
that they will not um continue releasing
stellar single-player campaigns because
if they have you know zynga and they
have all these mobile games and they
have these properties that people love
surefire way to keep people really
loving the properties that you're making
is to have a studio with a portfolio
like rockstar continuing to make stellar
first-class
like world-class you know best-selling
highly esteemed video games that is a
thing that they have in their portfolio
that they don't have from a lot of the
other studios that they own that i can't
imagine them wanting to lose so i think
you can continue to expect uh take to to
monetize the pants out of
rockstar properties
and everything else they own you know
that's that's that's like their whole
job
i do not believe and again hopefully i'm
not being too generous i do not believe
that this means that uh rockstar will
not continue to make good single-player
experiences and take their time in
making them and one upside to take two
continuing to make more money is that
gta 6 has more money
it has that development money we know
how expensive gta 5 was to make it was
colossal
you can't really do that uh without you
know making tremendous profits though to
be honest gt online probably could have
funded it entirely by itself but if
there's anything you need to know about
these publicly traded companies it's
that healthy profit is not enough there
must always be more profit year over
year they must make more money there's
no million seems pretty good well that's
cool it has to be more than that it has
to be more because if you aren't seen as
profiting more than you profited the
previous year they would consider that a
failure
i do also think there is something to be
said for how terribly it would go down
if rockstar or take two were to announce
that rockstar was no longer making
single-player games the outrage for that
would be enormous the amount of love
that they would lose i feel like i so
often say like what you say doesn't
matter to the games industry but uh when
you know
it's easy to see that shareholders may
have bought in to take two because they
have such a games industry gem like
rockstar i actually do think that
um
it would hurt them on the stock market
if they got rid of that absolute gaming
gem which always makes news headlines
and is the one that your parents know
they know grand theft auto but yes
ultimately a really interesting thing to
talk about something that i do not find
surprising in the slightest and
something that doesn't make me think we
will not get
single player campaigns going forward
you are likely just to see other facets
of rockstar franchises monetized out the
ass thank you for that question it's a
fun thing to talk about i love talking
about that kind of stuff it is time to
talk about keeps keeps is a subscription
service that helps men keep their hair
of course there's no magic cure for
baldness but keeps does offer clinically
proven treatments to combat the symptoms
of hair loss treatment plans are
affordable typically half the cost of
pharmacy prices and all treatment plans
are personalized and doctor recommended
and fda approved which you love to see
one particularly cool thing is that
keeps comes with 24 7 expert support
that is treatment plans that come with a
year of unlimited doctor messaging so
you can talk to expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists to
support you in making your hair goals a
reality so it is time to take action
with keeps you can get quality expert
care without ever visiting a doctor's
office or a pharmacy and it is totally
normal to ask for help because two out
of three guys will experience hair loss
by the time they're 35. it is all about
getting a routine that works for you
whether you're looking to prevent hair
loss stimulate hair growth or just take
better care of the hair you have keeps
has you covered hair loss stops with
keeps to get fifty percent off your
first order go to keeps.com slash
orlando pierce or click the link in the
description that is k-e-e-p-s dot com
slash alana pierce connolly fast it
recently came out that ghost sushima
sold 8 million copies an incredible
milestone the game director of days gone
took to twitter and commented that their
game had also hit this milestone but no
such appraisal was given by execs in
fact quite the opposite
question what do you suspect is a nuance
of this specific scenario is it the mass
critical acclaim of ghost the buggy slow
start for days gone even though it grew
legs if both games hit the same
milestone why is one considered more
successful than the other obviously it'd
just be your speculation but i love your
takes because of your deeper knowledge
in the industry thank you i do want to
be very clear that this is just
speculation i do not know obviously
i work at sony
and i do not have any insider knowledge
to any of this kind of thing whatsoever
i have friends at these studios but uh i
i do not
i don't get invited to these [ __ ]
sales meetings okay i don't i don't know
anything valuable really so first i
think that um this sucked a bit uh i
feel like goes to tsushima tweeted
something celebrating a milestone and it
was like very quickly taken away from
them and all of the news articles
changed to be about days gone and not
about ghost of tsushima which i just
feel like really sucks for suck a bunch
um i felt bad for them i think that um
the director who used to be at bend who
no longer works there was totally fair
to to feel that way and it's not his
fault actually that everything turned
kind of against sucker punch i blame the
media for that one more than anything um
but also just a lot of regular old
people on twitter like
can't we just like why are we angry at
sucker punch like there was so much like
yeah what about [ __ ] days gone like
when i just tweeted something positive i
just feel like it's a huge bummer so
outside of that uh if i were to guess it
would be that daze gone did poorly on
metacritic in comparison to ghost to
sushima the critical reception um which
i definitely think matters to
the first party uh publishers which i've
said a million times definitely matters
they definitely care about metacritic
some third parties do too but of course
when you're at you know xbox or nintendo
or playstation if you are trying to
convince people to buy your exclusives
you need those exclusives to get really
good review scores so that you can say
this is the only place that you can play
this incredible game this is the only
one so people are like damn i gotta get
me
a whatever console because that's the
only place that i can play this thing
that is everyone's game of the year [ __ ]
it's market you're making really [ __ ]
good games as marketing so if they don't
have the 95 out of 100 i can imagine it
being a lot less appealing
to uh a platform holder to those kinds
of execs um because you are not
contributing uh as healthily to that
marketing machine second though um he
did say i think he clarified that it was
execs at bend that had the problem and
third uh i do not believe those sales
statistics to be accurate not only does
it seem like day's gone probably hasn't
actually sold eight million copies um
day's gone also had
numerous sales where gosu tsushima did
not
if you remember there was also somebody
at ben who tweeted not too long ago that
you shouldn't buy
games on sale if you want to support dev
studios
which naturally they have the experience
to talk about
being that that game was on sale
multiple times so
it's just
not really the same i don't think it's a
it's a nuance issue i think it's that
they probably didn't sell eight million
copies that was a guess
based on a website that um is just not
accurate uh and a lot of industry
analysts suspected that it probably sold
a little bit less again another great
question i love these kinds of questions
whenever i get to talk about this side
of the games industry i light up i get
very excited thank you what a great q a
but yes of course again i do not have
any insider knowledge and i don't want
to like add any fuel to this fire i
think it's awesome for sucker punch and
full support to bend it must also be
very frustrating for them as a studio if
they potentially didn't actually get the
sales statistics it seems wild to me and
this is my first time learning this that
a game director might not necessarily
know how many units a game is sold that
seems that seems wild
i answered this one in the comments but
i'm gonna do it anyway darren g this is
regarding game awards said it's all
rigged or fake the fact that death loop
gets a game of the year nod but neither
eternal or ratchet is mind-blowing
i promise you
people just have different opinions to
you if you think that somebody
shouldn't be able to think
that a different game is game of the
year from what you would have picked
but it makes sense to you that people
can have different religions i feel like
there's a disconnect
you're like okay these two people
literally think the universe was created
by a different [ __ ] entity and that
they should live by these two different
entities and you're like yeah that makes
sense but if someone's like death loops
my game of the year you're like rigged
people are different man people think
differently that's it i promise that's
it
craig wells question for gaming i get
very anxious while playing horror games
you can't make it past the opening scene
of any horror game any advice on how to
power through so i can play games like
r8 and inscription um inscription i
don't know that i would call it a horror
game it's definitely unsettling i can
see how it'd make you anxious
so
uh i love horror games survival horror
is my favorite genre of video game uh
when i started out reviewing games there
was a period of time where i worked for
a program where i had to review three
games a week that was a lot of [ __ ]
games in some cases the games were
pretty bad um but that was almost always
the most fun reviews to write when you
get to be really scathing about
something it is definitely the most fun
to write the middling reviews are the
hardest the really positive ones are
easy really negative ones are fun the
middling ones are difficult and uh
i certainly
used to be pretty bad with horror games
and have trouble playing through them
but my love has only grown and i think
that having to review
random steam releases helped because a
lot of those random steam releases are
horror games they're also often short
which sometimes if i was trying to fill
that quota without spending 100 hours in
a week i would try to play shoulder
games
um
and what i started to do was just run
just always run
if you've watched my horror let's plays
on youtube you would know that i still
don't often do that but if i'm trying to
get through something and not like
savoring that that moment savoring the
fear and the anxiety because it's
something that i actually really enjoy
uh if i'm trying to get through
something i just run and my logic when i
was reviewing horror games was
well if i just run through it
then nothing can jump at me because
everything is already moving quickly
and that kind of works so i would
genuinely try that if playing games is
causing you anxiety i don't know that
this will help but it is worth giving a
shot just if you are feeling anxious or
afraid don't hesitate just continue
moving and then at the very least
you get rid of the fear of like what's
around that corner
i also certainly stopped having as much
trouble with horror games
when i started becoming extremely
familiar with level design and that's
something that has plagued me for the
last i don't know
maybe decade probably not quite that
long i can now kind of tell when
something's going to come out of a
certain area in a horror game just based
on the way a room looks and i didn't
realize
how different
i
was approaching that to most people
until i played um i think was the evil
within with an ex-boyfriend and he was
very scared of something and i was like
but
clearly that box is there
it's because it's gonna run around here
and this is gonna happen and as you play
more of them
you start to kind of learn those tricks
and so they get a little bit easier
alright that is it from me today
everybody i
will see you guys next time thanks to
keeps for sponsoring this video as they
do and yeah if you want to leave
questions for the next two q a's gaming
or personal leave them below see you
guys next time